[MUSIC].
I'm sorry about that, Andy, I'm sorry about that, viewers at home. But now I'm
back, I'm good and now we're ready for one of my favorite senses, hearing.
&gt;&gt; It's alright Lauren, I really had no idea that a smell could bring back such an
emotional response.
&gt;&gt; Anyways the event we're about to do now is all about the sensation and
perception of sound.
&gt;&gt; Really, Andy. And now, I think myself included, that our viewers would like to
know what exactly is sound?
&gt;&gt; Well, sound is a wave.
&gt;&gt; Now what do you mean by wave?
&gt;&gt; So, let's take a look at sound with our patented UdaciTablet system. So, sound
is just a pressure wave through the air, and air is just a bunch of molecules
spread out like this. And here, each little black dot is just an air molecule.
And when something like a speaker, which I've drawn here, makes a sound, it
does so by vibrating this part back and forth. So, it would go forward and
backwards, and forwards, and backwards, and so on. And this actually causes all
of the air molecules to bunch up in some places, like this. And you can see
regions where there are a high density of air molecules. And region where
there's a low density. And this, in turn, creates region of high pressure, and
regions of low pressure.